[Music]
storms ravaged cities around the world
the new york city subway system shut
down the city received over 200
millimeters of rainfall the highest
since 2015.
as the climate crisis worsens extreme
weather events are becoming ever more
common
and these concrete jungles aren't
exactly helping infrastructure is
impermeable so often you get flooding
because the water's got nowhere to go
in fact the industry that builds this
infrastructure is making things worse
eleven percent of the world's carbon
emissions come from construction we
cannot afford to carry on business as
usual in two years china poured more
concrete than the usa did in the whole
of the last century so how can humans
build without it costing the earth we
have three kids we have their futures to
think about our future to think about
[Music]
nareed and mozamel and their three kids
live in the bay area of san francisco
they bought their house three years ago
but now with a growing family they need
more space i'm thinking that in order to
give us more space in our bedroom we
just build out eight feet this way
when we bought the house we had really
grand plans to add a thousand square
feet and make it a huge home
and then we spent some time researching
and analyzing and really going through
it there's a lot of good things about
living with less there's less cost for
heating and cooling but then that impact
on the environment we really made a
conscious decision we've now scaled it
back to about 100 square feet
so we're headed to
the primary bedroom
we don't have a ton of closet space so
really only my things fit in this
bedroom whereas mizzy's things are
actually out in the hallway
the environment has always been close to
mozamel's heart we can go out from the
back something he made clear to nareed
on their very first date i told her she
was perfect except for the fact that she
didn't recycle
and it was understandable that she
didn't recycle she explained to me
because
she lived on a four fourth floor walk-up
that had an opera white side of
manhattan that had foot ceilings so
every time i had like one bottle living
as a single person i'd have to go down
four flights of stairs to take it into
the recycling so he made me invest into
a recycling container that he then would
take out yes once a week i got the
exercise at that point
the couple's plan to extend their home
may now be more modest but they're just
as determined that the work does as
little harm to the environment as
possible
and there's one very familiar material
that really concerns them
this one factory is now turning out 15
000 concrete slabs enough for 35 houses
every week
it seems like concrete's been around
forever
it was the romans who first started
using it for everything from aqueducts
to the pantheon
today it is the second most used
resource on the planet after water
the big users of concrete at the moment
are countries like china and southeast
asia
i've seen reports that in two years they
poured more concrete in china than the
usa did in the whole of the last century
and of course that's associated with
huge carbon emissions
at imperial college professor chris
cheeseman is an expert in all things
concrete concrete is an amazing material
if you think about what it does
we take a grey powder we mix it with
some aggregate stones basically and some
finer sand type materials and we mix
those with water and it's flowable you
can pour it you can make it into a shape
and then like by magic it turns into a
rock
the grey powder is cement it's the
all-important glue in concrete
but it's the biggest culprit when it
comes to carbon emissions
the five billion tonnes of cement
produced each year account for eight
percent of the world's man-made co2
emissions
among materials only coal oil and gas
are a greater source of greenhouse gases
helsinki finland this unassuming city
has an ambitious target becoming carbon
neutral by 2035
and is already a global leader in
climate-related technology innovation
researchers here have taken up a
seemingly impossible challenge to make
concrete without its most problematic
ingredient cement
business worldwide simply cannot
continue at the current rate we must
find new sustainable means through
innovation and technology
materials technology company betola has
spent five years working on an answer
inspiration for the company's
cement-free solution came from the
mountains of waste being produced by
other industries
using artificial intelligence it
analyzes local industrial waste and
generates the right recipes to produce
its composite cement alternative
we take industrial waste for example
from steel production and we combine it
with alkali activating solution and by
this way we can reduce the co2 emissions
of concrete raw materials even up to 80
percent
as well as this potentially huge
reduction in the scale of emissions
there are other obvious benefits to
using waste products or side streams by
providing the possibility to use the
side streams we are actually giving a
new life for this waste instead of
landfilling into the environment
it's an ingenious solution but even
given the extent of industrial waste
questions remain about its scalability
although the steel industry is a huge
industry in comparison with concrete
production it's relatively small there's
just not enough waste materials they're
not going to transform construction in
the way that we might want to
transforming construction might instead
mean weaning the industry of its
reliance on concrete altogether
in this english county 25 new houses are
nearing completion
it looks like a fairly traditional
residential building site but behind
these walls it's anything but
[Applause]
hemp it's not generally used in
construction and that's got some quite
unique properties
hemp is another name for a very familiar
plant with a colourful history
[Music]
but unlike cannabis
industrial hemp contains only tiny
traces of the chemical that gets people
high
it has some other things going for it
though
it grows incredibly fast
its fibres are also surprisingly strong
what we're doing here is using the woody
core of the plant which is called shiv
and we're just mixing it with lime to
make a rigid insulation material it's
fire proof it also has fantastic thermal
inertia so when external temperatures
fluctuate up and down the internal
temperature of the house stays very
constant it's just generally a good
insulator and it's locking up carbon
this is about 300 square meters so if
you scale that up this house if it was
built in a conventional way would be
responsible for somewhere between 150
and 200 tons of co2 emissions we're able
to get that to zero so that's a massive
carbon saving at the construction stage
as well as the fact that it will be
operationally zero energy going forward
as well
hemp used in this way can clearly help
deliver significant reductions in carbon
emissions
but its nickname hemp crete might be a
little misleading
it's an interesting material but you're
not going to build major infrastructure
out of hemp feet you might build an
extension or even a house out of heavy
creek but it's not going to compete with
concrete as we know it because it just
doesn't have the mechanical properties
and strength and durability probably as
well
here greencore isn't working with hemp
alone though it's building with wood
and as the search for sustainability
grows so does the revival of interest in
the potential of this age-old material
at cambridge university's school of
architecture michael ramage and his team
are taking inspiration from the past to
inspire the construction industry to new
heights in the future
oakwood tower was a demonstration
project and a research project to show
that building really tall in wood was
possible so we engineered this 300 meter
tower for central london and we showed
that it was possible for it to stand up
whilst oakwood tower is just a proof of
concept it's based on innovations that
have transformed the load-bearing
strength of wood in the last few decades
a new category of engineered timber has
emerged in particular cross-laminated
timber which are
very big engineered materials made of
wood that are strong and they can be
used as replacements for
steel and concrete in buildings of all
sizes
clt is constructed in a controlled
factory environment by gluing layers of
wood at 90 degrees to each other the
layers are then hydraulically pressed
together creating high strength
structural panels
using computer controlled joinery
machines any shape of panel can be cut
before being transported to site
timber building sites tend to be much
quieter than other building sites
because they go together mostly with
battery-powered drills construction is
much quicker because the timber arrives
on site pre-fabricated like flat pack
furniture and it gets lifted into sight
by a crane
while high rises are lots of fun to
design and an interesting challenge to
engineer most of the buildings that we
need are not high rises and are ideal
for building in cross-laminated timber
but one thing everyone knows is that
wood burns
for many fears would be fueled by the
prospect of wood-built cities going up
in flames
cross-laminated timber is is of course
wood and it will always be a combustible
material but we know how to make
fire-safe designs in cross-laminated
timber there are a range of different
strategies so that fires don't spread if
they do start and so that the wood in
many cases is not exposed to the fire
it's often behind layers of plasterboard
but one of the big challenges with
wooden buildings is that the wood is
lovely to look at and architects and
clients and engineers want to expose the
wood as much as possible and that is a
challenge for the fire safety so making
those two aspirations work together is
something that all of us i think in this
area are working on and hoping to solve
in 2018 55 of the world population lived
in urban areas and that is expected to
grow to 68 by 2050
they will need homes to live in offices
to work in and more of the
infrastructure people rely on
the construction industry's got its work
cut out and it faces a monumental effort
if it's to become truly sustainable as
well as novel use of old materials from
industrial waste to hemp or timber more
new solutions are going to be needed
every company out there is pushing the
green agenda i think the pull is really
coming from the customers
people want low carbon buildings now
there's a big big pool for that
rather than doing the things we've done
in the past i think designers and
architects need to look at how we use
materials so that they're used in a way
that gets the most performance out of
them and we don't waste materials see it
depends when we build it out and for
people like massimo and neureed it
always comes down to the same thing
money
being green
isn't cheap
i think for folks like us where you have
limited funds but understand the
morality of making these choices i think
we frequently run up against what's at
all worth and justifying spending more
money in order to uphold our values
i'm john fassman the economist u.s
digital editor to keep up with all our
climate change coverage click the link
thanks for watching and don't forget to
subscribe
you